great now right to Part B now if I ask
you to find the distance from A to B
again our normal strategy is we'll find
where a is find where B is and then do
your to point distance formula okay
which as you can see is a long Secours
process finding a B I'm gonna solve this
there the distance formula itself is
kind of a gross object so I'm seeking to
avoid it and the question gives you a
clue for how to do this okay so it says
using this now I just want you to look
at that for a second
[Applause]
they Sleeper really interested in
political techniques obviously when you
see the absolute value of alpha minus
beta just on its own just when you see
that right what does that make you think
how am I supposed to get to that thing
hmm
what is the absolute value yeah okay
so excuse me there are many definitions
for the absolute value when we add value
earlier this year I said to you here's a
whole bunch of definitions some are more
useful than others
this one here looked like a kind of
weird one like why would you do that
why would you think of it as just take
the positive value and the answer is it
gives you an algebraic way to get to
this thing if you can work out what the
right-hand side is okay now that's good
I'm going to use this in a second but I
want to ask a second question like what
does this even mean the absolute value
of something right like when I say the
absolute value of negative 5 we know its
value is but what does it mean what is
its geometric meeting yeah Magna G is a
good way to go but I'm thinking about
and it's very close I'm thinking about
this question that I'm trying to answer
it's really the distance what made it to
means is the distance of this thing from
the origin does that any sense how far
is this number there it is
how far is it from the origin and the
answer is it's five units from the
origin right okay I'm gonna pushing this
one more
he would be okay what does that mean you
know what the answer is but what does it
mean think about it through this lens
right
think about it through this lens what it
means is not the distance to the origin
that's what this is this is the distance
between these two numbers like the
distance between these two is for isn't
it which is why it's the same as um as
this becomes that distance is the same
no matter which way you're going okay so
therefore what does this mean it's the
distance between what and what
it's the distance between this value and
this value where are they on my diagram
well down here I have alpha 2 alpha
right so alpha is the x coordinate over
here I've got better to beat up so where
an alpha and beta and the answer is this
is the distance this distance here can
you see why why is it this distance
alpha a beta a which coordinates are
they X or Y corners they're both x
coordinates right alpha a beta so that
means when I'm thinking of x coordinates
I'm thinking about horizontal things
right excuse me I'm not thinking about
vertical things alpha is over there on
the Left beta is over here on the right
so the distance between them is by
definition the absolute value of alpha
minus beta so in other words if I find
that using this thing that Eric
suggested earlier we're all going to do
if I find that then I have this
horizontal distance okay I'm going to
show you how we can get from there to
this length distance ay B which is we're
actually gonna try and find okay let's
find out this alpha minus beta thing
first so I write the absolute value of
alpha minus beta is equal to the square
root of what alpha minus beta squared
San okay like I'm just done bit of
substitution okay
this I could also work out right this
thing here do you recognize you've
actually worked this out before okay
this is alpha squared minus 2 alpha beta
plus beta squared yeah that looks
familiar which is itself let's see here
alpha squared plus 2 alpha beta plus
beta squared minus 4 Alpha Beta why am i
doing this why am i adding and
subtracting alpha vader's why am i on
collecting like terms
no fantastic yeah go on finish your
thought okay excellent
so let's do let's do the factorization
that fedora is suggesting so I've got
alpha plus beta or squared and I know
what that value is right I haven't
worked out alpha beta yet but it's not
very hard because where did I write it
there it is there's the quadratic where
I can get my product of rich rope so
let's do both of these alpha plus beta
we worked out to be 4 so that gives me
16 at the front what is the product of
roots from this thing what is alpha beta
it's just negative 8 isn't it what's
negative 8 on 1 which is negative 8 so
I've got minus 4 lots of negative 8 that
okay that's 32 16 plus 32 is 48 the
square root of 48 what's the biggest
square I can take out of that 16 so I'm
pretty sure that's 4 root 3 ok now
what's this mean well this tells me that
this distance here is 4 root 3 okay now
if you know this distance see where I'm
trying to go by the way I am after this
length here
maybe that's what I'm trying to find you
know this leg trying to find that leaf
what kind of shape are these in this is
a right angle triangle right right so
all I need is another length here the
other shorter leg and then I can just
use Pythagoras like that's so much
easier than having to go around find
points of just
all my kind of thing okay is there a
quick way I've got my horizontal left
out here is there a quick way I can find
it it's further cooling look have a
think so I can what I can do is I I know
that this distance here is 2 beta minus
2 alpha right to be Nomos to alpha I
want the difference between those do you
agree right but but look at that for a
second look at it it's a 2 so I'm just
going to take that at the front like so
that's a common factor right but this is
the absolute value so actually it
doesn't matter which way I do this thing
because if that was 5 then it'll be the
same as negative 5 so this is 2 times
alpha minus beta as well the absolute
value does that make sense but but I
know what this thing is I just worked it
out
here it is right I should write that so
therefore all I have to do is double it
it's going to be 8 root 3 is that okay
another way you can see that I really
like that way by the way another way you
can see it the way I prepare it was that
this thing here this triangle right it's
the kind of dry triangle you draw when
you're trying to work out gradient yeah
rise over run gives you the gradient
yeah except you actually already know
the gradient of this line don't you
what's the gradient it's two so if you
run one unit you should rise two units
if you run for three units then you
should rise double that does that make
sense both of those are fine I think
this is a nice way to go back okay so
now that I know what the vertical
distance is all I need is Pythagoras
right so I can say in conclusion the
distance ay B is let's see here
it's the hypotenuse so that's why I'm
squaring it it's going to be this
squared plus this squared that's four th
because that was the square root of 48
plus someone help me out
sixty-four times three is that 192 don't
fit this is keeping the calculator cuz I
don't trust my brain is ahead an OG yep
48 plus hundred ninety-two
is 240 240 so distance a V is the square
root of turning-point that okay yes no I
did that all on my head so I'm
inherently suspicious but if people are
nodding at me and they've tried to
calculator then that's a good thing okay
last one and this time I'm gonna pause
from holding your hair because I think
given this kind of giving me showing you
how you can use this summon products of
roots business to solve these questions
right which you might not have thought
of instinctively I want you to now have
a look at Part C okay I will give you a
nudge in the right direction normally
when you see where tangent what topic do
you think of you normally think of
calculus cuz you like I've gotta find
the derivative so I can get gradient
does it up okay but I'm trying to tell
you when you've got polynomial
techniques they give you another Avenue
into questions my suggestion is you do
not need calculus to find this answer
okay I will let you have a thinking
about how otherwise you could do it I'm
using similar kind of polynomial
techniques give you three four minutes
to have a shot at it on your own see
what you can come up with